the liver is the body's metabolic HQ
detoxifying the blood making proteins
and hormones aiding digestion and
processing nutrients most people know it
best as the organ that clears up after a
night in the pub and the heavy drinking
can cause severe damage but it's
actually non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease ornithol v that now has doctors
and scientists worried linked to the
global increase in obesity one in four
people has a fatty liver when calories
are well matched to the body's energy
consumption the liver orchestrates an
ebb and flow of energy storage and
distribution but when fat and
carbohydrate flood the liver the system
becomes overwhelmed and stops working
properly if more than 5% of cells in a
person's liver contain large fat
droplets that person is said to have a
non-alcoholic fatty liver at this stage
a fatty liver is still reversible with
changes to diet and exercise but without
intervention things can get much worse
leading to cell death and chronic
inflammation
if this happens Nathalie becomes a
condition called gnash unchecked it
increases the risk of cardiovascular
disease and serious liver problems
including cancer and cirrhosis which is
when scar tissue forms in the liver
treating nash is crucial but even at
advanced stages its symptoms can be
vague and doctors struggle to diagnose
it currently we need a slice of your
liver hold the fava beans and Chianti to
spot fat depositions inflammation and
scar tissue but there has to be an
easier way scientists are developing an
accurate blood test or we can look to
the coolest guy in the hospital new more
sensitive ways of detecting how
ultrasound waves change provides a
picture of how much fat and scar tissue
is in a liver numerous studies have
shown that diet and exercise can reverse
fatty liver and even Nash but lifestyle
change can be the trickiest prescription
of all and if nash continues to worsen
doctors will want to intervene
currently there are no drugs
specifically approved for treating Nash
however hundreds of drug trials are
underway some drugs act in the gut
halting fat absorption and stopping the
release of pro-inflammatory signals most
target the liver directly aiming to stop
the metabolic stress the triggers
novelty others try to prevent nash by
blocking the effects of metabolic stress
by stopping inflammation and cell death
and some drugs are making progress on
that difficult scar tissue livers work
relentlessly to keep us going and
researchers are working ceaselessly to
to better understand diagnose and treat
this increasingly common condition
helping us all live a healthier life
you